a lot of EDH discourse exists around the
concept of removal and specifically
around the question of whether people
should be running more of it in that
great battle of ideas I fall firmly in
the camp of incessantly telling people
to run more removal I will happily be
that annoying guy however I also
understand why this advice might not be
enjoyable to receive for a lot of people
in conventional EDH deck building ways
to interact with your opponents often
ends up in the category of vegetables
it's a type of card that's not flashy or
exciting but that you need to include
regardless if you're building a cool EDH
deck around a particular idea sloughing
off deck space to spend on interaction
might feel disappointing you're
effectively diluting the quality of
what's happening on your side of the
board in order to set back opponents if
this line of thinking sounds like you I
understand that and I'm not here to
perform the role of the chiding parent
telling you that you need to grit your
teeth and choke down those vegetables
there certainly are plenty of reasons to
run more ways to interact with opponents
the two big ones are that it leaves you
a better rounded deck and it leads to
more Dynamic and interesting games
rather than luck based one-sided Stomps
but no I don't want to focus on that
because on some level you probably
already know that rather I want to offer
an alternative Vision to the vegetables
analogy what if you could have all the
benefits of running a lot of removal
without feeling like it's gobbling up
your deck space I'm going to talk about
a couple methods for accomplishing this
task and the first method is to make the
slots you're already spending on removal
do more more for you when we look at the
most popular removal spells in the EDH
format it's mostly single Target removal
typically either lowcost options or All
Purpose options that can hit any Target
to be clear these things absolutely have
their place but they are an entire deck
slot spent removing one card what if
there are two concerning cards on board
what if somebody plays another one the
turn after you remove something running
enough single Target removal for all
potential targets can really tax your
deck space and there are two
Alternatives that can be comparatively
compact multi- removal and removal
engines multi- removal is exactly what
it sounds like it's a spell that removes
multiple potential threats board wipes
are one example of this but there are
plenty of other options some of these
are pretty straightforward whole breach
can destroy both an artifact and an
enchantment and soul shatter forces each
opponent to sacrifice a hopefully
valuable creature or Plaines Walker
however as you get to higher Mana costs
there are some spicier options too wind
Grace's judgment can destroy each
opponent's most valuable nonl permanent
and both de and casualties of War are
capable of blasting cards of several
card types all at once a really cool
thing about these is that you'll
typically destroy one or two things that
are currently problems but also a couple
things that might cause problems down
the road a big Mana Rock a utility land
or a low-level value enchantment won't
be priority targets for removal that can
only target one thing but being able to
clear out multiple of these at the same
time as a higher value Target can really
pay off in the long term in terms of
denied Advantage removal engines are
another way to make your interaction
Suite more Compact and these are cards
that can destroy things over time AA
shards is one of the most powerful
examples of this but there are also
creatures like Royal assassin and Trigon
Predator that can remove one permanent
per turn removal engines can also
involve multiple carts and you'll find
this most often in control decks in my
shirom slide deck the singular control
deck in my current lineup of decks there
are only two cards in the list that
could reasonably be described as board
wipes however the deck frequently
engages in heavy degrees of board
suppression through the usage of removal
engines astral slide can recycle
explosive etbs including that of one of
the board wipes and there are also a
number of ways to get control pieces in
and out of the graveyard the deck even
has a stifle engine what kind of goofy
deck has a stifle engine in it other
examples of this might include a pinger
paired with a death touch enabler
containment priest paired with a flicker
engine and molda paired with a flush bag
Marauder effect in general these are
great for conserving deck space in a
toolbox control deck that has networks
of ways to find different cards a small
handful of removal engines can free up a
ton of deck space to go toward counter
spells Tech pieces draw and other
categories that might otherwise have to
be a bit leaner to fit an adequate
amount of removal now I should say in
the case of both multi- removal and
removal engines you're generally going
to pay more Mana for the added benefits
as compared to single Target
counterparts of these cards and for the
leanest most unapologetically proactive
decks out there that extra cost will
likely be an unacceptable down side but
not all decks fit that description we've
seen lowcost allpurpose removal become
the quote unquote staple Choice even
though plenty of decks absolutely can
afford to pay a little more Mana in
order to get more out of their removal
board wipes are the model of this that
most people are familiar with and these
are nice but not perfect they often
destroy your stuff as well and another
downside with them goes back to the
temporality of removal if you purely
focus on blasting all the creatures off
the board you'll be safe to turn the
board wipe is cast but a lot of decks
can bounce back shockingly quickly from
a board wipe or even mitigate it
entirely your opponents have been
through this before you're not catching
some deey Timmy offu with the first
wrath of God he's ever seen in his life
this isn't to say that you need to avoid
board wipes they're a great option for a
lot of situations but if you're
considering your fourth or fifth board
wipe for a deck maybe consider that
there are other options out there for
accomplishing a similar task okay so
that was the method of densifying the
part of your deck that you dedicate to
removal the second method is to widen
your removal Suite but to make an effort
to pick out removal that blends into the
rest of what your deck is doing this
allows it to feel less space gobling
even as the number of removal cards in
your deck stays High one way of doing
this is picking out cards that align
with your deck synergies and this is
typically easier the more General your
deck synergies are one of the most
General options is card type if you're
running a deck based around artifacts or
around instense and sorceries I can
guarantee you that there are a ton of
options for interaction that will slot
in nicely with the Synergy core of your
deck
this is similarly doable in Decks that
Focus around core game mechanics there
are lots of great options for decks
based around counters tokens and
graveyards for a few examples of
synergistic picks you could run drowning
ier in a deck with a focus on counters
you could run Trigon predator in a deck
that is looking for evasive attackers
and you could run lethal scheme in a
deck that gets a wide Board of creatures
and wouldn't mind a bit of extra
filtering an extension of this principle
is modal cards cards like valorous
stance Silverback Elder and gx's command
are solid for both removal and non-
removal purposes there are also plenty
of cards that are effectively modal
without explicitly invoking the word
choose L cycling cards like Angel of the
ruins as well as mdfc come to mind the
important thing is that these cards
allow a deck to pack a lot of removal
that can be used when needed but not
feel like its deck slots are being
actively gobbled up this leads to more
fluid gameplay since these cards can be
lands or Draw or ramp or protection in
addition to being removal this is also
why counter spells are good if you can
afford to hold up without falling behind
but this is a video about removal spells
so I'll leave it at that as an example
of removal blending in my friend Hans
has a deck he likes to call is it bit
it's a Lila undefeated slick shot deck
that runs as many prophetic bolt style
cards as it can possibly get its hands
on we're talking any red blue instant or
sorcery that both deals damage and draws
cards in some capacity as a result of
this even though the deck is packed out
to the Wazoo with creature removal since
almost all of that removal draws cards
and works with the commander as well it
feels perfectly fine another example of
this is myada deck and that deck
actually takes advantage of both methods
I've mentioned in this video for the
blending in part all of the removal in
this deck is attached to either a big
creature or a Cascade spell this is
great because these are things I want
anyway Cascade spells will usually grab
me pieces of ramp to pump up my land
count and big creatures are what I use
to pressure life totals and eventually
win this is compounded by the density of
these a full seven of these are one card
removal engines and a single one of
these sticking around for multiple turns
on end can wildly warp the shape of a
game as a result of these things the
deck is very much so eating its removal
vegetables but when I play it it just
feels like a big dumb Cascade ramp deck
even as it eats opposing permanence at a
healthy Pace I've given a couple of nice
options for fitting more removal into a
deck densifying the existing removal
Suite through multi removal or removal
engines can let the same number of cards
do more and blending removal into the
rest of what deck is doing through
synergistic or modal options can
similarly offer more removal in practice
without it feeling like it's hogging too
much Deck space however putting these
options into practice requires
understanding what removal is actually
doing for your deck even in this a video
about removal I've so far largely
abstracted away what removal is actually
accomplishing in a game letting it sit
simply assumed that it's a good thing to
have so what is removal doing for Su
decks this is a question with a clear
specific ific answer in my Francisco
Malcolm deck a deck that fits the lean
and unapologetically proactive
descriptor I mentioned earlier removal
principally exists to kill creatures
that threaten my turn five to six win or
that might allow opponents to win faster
than that if I'm playing the deck and my
opponents play out some scary engine
creature on turn four to five I don't
generally need to remove these as long
as my combo is on track to end the game
before those creatures have a chance to
cause problems for this reason all of
the decks dead ated removal is 2 Mana or
less to allow it to be weaved into a
turn comfortably I run the lowcost
Staples because I don't need to care
what's happening on board two turns from
now similarly I run a lot of Mana
efficient single Target removal in My
Maria deck as well because it's a
Voltron deck player removal is
absolutely on the table so my removal is
there to deal with obstacles to my beat
down rather than controlling the board
by contrast I run removal engines in my
slower grinder decks because the time
frame for winning is a lot less concrete
I'll usually have some tools to put
pressure on opponents relatively early
but the plan to win isn't focused enough
to be relied upon as any sort of clock
to calibrate the rest of my game plan
against thus in these sorts of decks my
removal exists to let me stay alive and
prevent opponents from winning for some
unknown duration of time and as a result
I need to prepare for a wider range of
situations and run removal that works
better in the longer term there will
also be the question of instant speed
removal versus sorcery speed removal and
this will come down down to power level
above all else if you're playing at
higher powers where sudden infinite
combo attempts might happen and
especially if you're not playing blue to
allow for counter spells instant speed
removal will likely be kind of a must
likewise if you're holding up removal at
instant speed just in case you also want
that removal to cost as little as
possible in order to avoid wasted Mana
if the removal is unneeded Staples are
Staples for a reason and this is
basically the reason you might even want
to include a handful of these in a
slower midow deck just for the sake of
contingencies they're good cards and if
you failed to slow down a player earlier
in their game plan having that insurance
policy to prevent a blowout can be
important however if you've already got
your first three or four single Target
Staples maybe try branching out a bit
from there and consider alternatives
that work better for your deck in
particular your deck will likely thank
you